và tỏng bên trong mẹ gấu nguyễn sẽ tự hủng lúc những sịp xin gệt bún tổng.
Xin ra, bài rứa là nhỏ gó, bài chặn ra thôi.
Tự chẳng thấy là có bài chặn ra là tối bây giờ,
phán tầm xấu từ phía lâu rồi.
Cậu không rời.
Nó ăn có cái đặc biệt là ngồi ăn rất là
Họng hình hưởng kế hậu mối
Chồng có hoa chình mình giống đoàn đi dục dòng dòng dòng mối ngoài của binh
Thì tởi nó an sẽ phát hệ và có đoàn cung đồng
Cái hay vì phúc nơi không thấy giải đất
Nhưng tởi bán người
Tởi bán tạo mốc, chảo nào bán đồng mốc thì chắc chắn là sẽ không mối
Bà mẹ có bán đúng chèu
Nhưng giờ nơi có ngó gái thái đổ là lắm lắm lắm lắm lắm lắm lắm
Sởi bán mẹ giúp là trong cái dợ em
Tất là hãy mở đo em được mang vào thì bán xói bán xói bán lạ lắm
Là rất là thong, giống như là bú cân của cân của cân
Bà mẹ có được đồng vạm, nhưng mà chế chuyển mà đánh nhau để chẳng dạm thích ăn để không cân